what is the problem here are you
embarrassed of me because of my husband
because you know that I'm writing that
book that it's gonna make everybody love
me again you're not really writing a
book well I already spent my advance so
that's the first step look this has been
a lot of fun but I need to start
thinking about my future I mean you
don't even respect me enough to have a
baby with me
well what I never explicitly said that
you set up with your actions what
actions oh look at that baby isn't he
the cutest baby you ever saw what what
what No
[Music]
[Applause]
misunderstanding officer I was running
away from my girlfriend whom I don't
respect enough to have a baby with Oh
face it you're afraid of commitment I'm
not afraid of commitment I commit to
things all the time it's the following
through on that commitment that I take
issue with hey stupid and that your
friend over there
Oh mr. peanut butter god I hope he
doesn't see us
it's that Bojack horseman oh geez here
we go mr. peanut butter and Bojack
horseman in the same room what is this a
crossover episode you know that gets
funnier every time you're being
sarcastic but I think it does actually
get funnier every time we're actually in
the middle of breaking up right now so
if you could just yeah you're in the
middle of it yeah that's right so would
it be awkward if I joined you right now
yes actually it's very awkward with is
that not clear yeah this is awkward
right now yes please leave how are you
mr. peanut butter Oh living the dream PC
living the dream why are you making
conversation
oh let's see it's the English short it's
called being polite Bojack but am I
crazy that this is a bad time I was a
Clydesdale never Clyde a Bojack what
you'll get that one later man we kill
you to be civil this is why we're
breaking up so it's not because of the
thing with the baby it's because of a
lot of things waiter could we please
have the check thank you we haven't even
ordered yet I have wasted so many
dinners on you Bojack horseman I don't
know how you can expect anyone else to
love you when you so clearly hate
yourself let me see that $10 for bread I
don't want to live in a society where
the Premio bread isn't free it is free
if you order a meal can you take me home
please yeah but I didn't even eat that
much bread what did I have I must have
had hate nine baskets sir nine but
really great now I'm gonna feel like a
fat ass all week
you